you've made it to part six and you're
powering along this arcad journey today
we're talking about objects and focusing
on the wet areas of the homes what's
going on guys my name is David tomich
I'm a registered architect here in
Western Australia and this is the
completely free arcad course available
to all of you right here on YouTube if
you missed any of the videos so far go
back to part one catch up to where we
are today because today is a very
important lesson that you do not want to
miss so today in part six we're going to
be focusing on objects and wet areas my
wet areas what I mean is the kitchen
laundry the bathroom and spaces where
typically water is running
primarily we're going to focus on the
bathroom and the laundry today to really
pinpoint exactly how you can utilize
archicad's objects and object Library
I'm going to dive into a very specific
kitchen tutorial in the next video So
today we're just focusing on these two
little spaces
to start off with we want to go into the
left hand panel here and select this
chair object that is our object tool if
we open it up by selecting the top or
command T you're going to see all of
your actual objects come up now same as
the doors and windows you can go back to
the little chair you can go to your
favorites or you can search for it by
simply typing what you want so for the
first of today we're going to go across
type in toilet and see what comes up now
what you see is ice have toilet 4D
available to me you will not this is
part of the 4D library and I prefer it
personally it is a paid accessory but
not everybody is going to have this so
we're going to stick to the actual
objects found in arcad by default
wc26 is the default toilet and there is
so many options to go through it is
fantastic just like doors and windows
and everything along the works you have
all of your three little key icons here
the image completely rendered out in 3D
and we can go through and change change
pretty much whatever we want how do we
want this toilet to look wall hung how
do we want the system to be in wall what
do we want our button to look like we
can go through a number of different
scenarios with the toilet now this stuff
is relatively boring so I will not go
through it immense detail because
there's no point most of the settings
are exactly the same as the doors and
windows and walls that we've talked
about so far they're just different
categories specific to the object every
single object you click on is going to
have a different format of settings in
it but it's all going to be relatively
consistent and you're going to be able
to work your way through it quite easily
two things to pay attention to is show
in 3D is if you want the system to be
shown and the actual object layer it's
on so for example it is on the wrong
layer for me personally you want MEP
Plumbing you want to press OK and then
when you click it's going to tell you
that this layer is hidden and what do
you want to do with it so personally I
just want to show it and see that to
other now for me when I'm designing wet
areas or anything really I like to get
all of the objects out and ready to go
so if we move our toilet across to the
side command D hit that option button
holding shift to make sure it's straight
command T opens up our settings I can
start utilizing the next object I need
in that wet area so let's type in shower
and see what we get again freeform multi
shout 4D uh basic 4D Library objects
which we're not going to be using which
can be used as standard shower cabin
from archicad I'm not going to go in and
change too many objects I'm just going
to create it for now and continue on the
last thing that I want inside this small
little bathroom is a vanity Basin now
arcad has a series of different styles
types basins cabinets and the works the
arcad 26 upgrade got a quite a decent
upgrade for the Cabinetry so if you want
to just simply use the cabinet you're
most welcome to it is a great little
object so pressing OK you'll see that we
have three objects created here we have
a toilet a shower and a hand Basin in a
small space like this if I press the M
for measure you'll see that it's 2.4 by
2.4 roughly internally now that isn't a
huge space but it does give us plenty of
space to do something with so let's
select our vanity Basin object press
command e for elephant which will open
up our rotate tool click in the center
hold shift let go of shift go all the
way up to 90 degrees whilst holding
shift to snap and finish clicking we'll
just simply going to rotate our vanity
Basin across now if I press command D to
help me move that vanity across I can
move my vanity directly in front of my
door so that when I walk into my
bathroom I'm not seeing a toilet I'm not
seeing a shower I'm directly engaging
with what I need the most now we're
going to select our shower command e
repeat that same step command D to move
along place it next to that vanity Basin
simply measure from there to our wall
and we'll see it's 900 wide personally
I'd like a meter so I'm going to press
command D move this up 100 Mil select on
my value Basin increase that from 900 to
a meter and then reposition it perfectly
across now you might be thinking what
the hell am I doing what's the plan here
well actually what I really want to do
is decrease the size of this laundry
increase the sizes bathroom and get a
little separate toilet going because I
don't personally like to have a toilet
free and open so when I'm going to do is
Select this wall drag it down place it
hard up against our shower and then go
command D press the option button to
duplicate that and simply type in 1200.
now you'll see I've created a new wall
and a new room to allocate space for
this toilet The Fill is now no longer
appropriate and no longer accurate so
I'm going to select my laundry and my
bathroom and just press delete I'm also
going to move my title of laundry up a
little bit and I'm going to select my
door command D move that up a little bit
as well now to make sure I have enough
room in my laundry I particularly want
about 1600 so looking up I have 1670 I'm
happy with that amount of space in my
laundry I can select these two walls
command iron like we've learned before
select my toilet command e rotate select
command D move it into place now
obviously we're going to need another
door so option
drag drop select that door and drop it
in if you haven't noticed we're
progressing a lot more in this tutorial
we're getting quicker we're getting
faster we're able to do things a lot
easier so hence why I'm not slowing it
down I'm not babying it for you guys
anymore you've learned a few skills
you've learned a few features and we
know what to do as I'm doing this live
in front of you
now if we go to our 3D view click our
little man down the bottom we can
explore our video by playing it like a
video game so let's continue to fly
through our internal space let's go into
our bathroom we'll see that our site is
clashing with our floor so command L to
open up our lasers type in site I'm
simply just going to hide the site
itself so we can see our floor very very
well you'll see that the Cabinetry is in
the window is clashing with our wall and
with our shower and our toilet is also
clashing with that window
so what we want to do is now we want to
come back to our ground floor plan we
want to readjust our window so we want
to align it to that space I personally
would also like to increase the size of
this shower let's go from 800 to 1500
and then move this door across so now
it's a nice large shower that you can
actually access from the side but
there's still a few little details
missing so first of all
let's just duplicate the shower command
T to change it and let's type in towel
because we're missing our towel rail so
by default you'll have a towel rail
style in archicad that you can select
from single bar for the purpose of this
is perfectly fine again I hate those
colors I really don't like them
personally so I'm just going to change
that to a black press ok
rotate around and drop my tower rail in
on the side next to this hand Basin
that's up to you guys where you want the
tower rail it could go next to the hand
Basin or you could rotate it once again
put it next to the toilet door so it's
directly in front of your actual shower
just depends where you want it just like
the handrail you also need a toilet roll
holder so if you type in the toilet
you'll get toilet paper dispenser you
can simply go wall mounted and rotate
that in drag drop it next to your toilet
coming back to our 3D images you'll see
that our window is still a little bit
too low so let's increase that window
seal height from 1800 to 2200 which will
now sit clear above our shower and it'll
be nice and quiet in this space you'll
see that the the tower rail is way too
low so let's lift that up to 900.
and fly away into our bathroom the
spaces are coming along very quickly
very easily and exactly as we want them
to look now you might be thinking it's
very challenging to fly around those
spaces and I don't really want to be
flying through walls all the time if
that's what you're thinking select this
Marquee tool and because we just want to
showcase this ground floor not
everything on all floors make sure
you've got the thin Marquee tool not the
thick Marky tool then what you want to
do is simply just cut off one wall two
walls or have many walls you don't want
to see right click show Marquee in 3D
and there you go we'll just show that
space that we've marked in 3D cut
everything open so we can actually see
what's going on this is a great way to
quickly see any space deep inside the
house and isolate individual elements
for example this way we can select our
Cabinetry and go no this is hideous I
don't like the tap style let's change it
to this font I don't like countertop
Edge let's change it here I don't like
sync let's make it a rectangle I want
the tap to be wall mounted I'd prefer
this style over the other one I want the
tap to be brass instead of metal you
have the freedom to quickly change
things go okay view it in 3D continue
adjusting and changing so let's say I
still don't like any of these elements I
can go through let's change our door
styles maybe I want to draw instead of
doors I can simply click on that let's
say I want the Cabinetry to be black I
want my door handles to be brass to
match the tap wear we want to count tone
to be white marble pressing okay we see
a massive change in our actual
architectural style of visual
representation and we can continue to
play with the interior design as we see
fit so obviously if we come back to our
ground floor plan now that's the
bathroom pretty much done it doesn't
take very long to drag and drop objects
in its archicad
but now let's come across to our laundry
our laundry might need to be a little
bit more detailed a little bit more
intricate so what do we do same kind of
system let's go into our object tool and
let's start by typing in laundry to see
what objects pop up because I have the
4D Library again there's a few more
objects that you won't see for you for
example I have a full laundry detailed
documented away you go you can simply
click OK drag and drop it into that
space in a matter of seconds and adjust
it how you see fit however you guys
won't have this available to you so
we're going to go through it one by one
and showcase individual items let's pick
our washing machine Let's Go a front
loader press OK drag and drop that
washing machine into the corner
duplicate it across command T let's get
our dryer same sort of deal open it up
we have our dryer we have our washing
machine now let's go into our little
chair icon to view everything we have
available to us scroll Down's kitchen
cabinetry and start utilizing some of
these elements now the kitchen cabinetry
is pretty basic we don't need too much
and it really depends what you want your
laundry to look like so for the purpose
of this let's just grab a base block
cabinet and I'm happy to have all
drawers for for the sake of argument I
do want to change this from Plumbing to
Furniture fixed press OK drag that into
the correct position and then what we
can do is simply drag drop duplicate a
number of these items across until we're
happy with the size if you have a little
bit of a awkward space left over you can
simply hit one of the hot spots hold
shift
extend it out all the way so that that
space is perfect for your requirements
now once again let's grab our Marquee
tool right click show Marquee in 3D and
let's have a quick look at our laundry
so laundry is relatively basic there's
not too much going on we probably want
to put a little bit more effort into
this if we were designing these spaces
rather than just dragging and dropping
objects in but let's say we don't like
this cupboard here command T let's grab
a standing cupboard we can adjust that
height to whatever we see fit so let's
say we want to drop it to the top of
this window and that's where we're going
to introduce a bulkhead next we might
not like that cupboard we might want to
go through our settings it might need a
sink or a trough and then you can adjust
what kind of sink you need pressing OK
we now have a sink in our laundry most
likely that sink would probably be a lot
closer
to our washing machine so we'd simply
drag that one across there move our sink
into the other position and then
increase our Cabinetry to match the Gap
coming back into our 2D floor plan
you'll see our laundry is pretty much
done if we wanted to add more we could
right click rotate drag and drop a
couple of these spaces in here add some
shelving decrease the depth of that only
300 and then we could Marquee our space
once again and for those who had some
extra wide cupboards here so instead of
just dragging that full width we'll
probably split it in half duplicate it
and then we have two large cupboards for
additional storage as we need and our
objects for the wet areas are very much
done now because there's no point going
into the bedrooms into another tutorial
I'm simply going to show you guys now
find a bed that you're relatively happy
with let's select this bed 26 because
it's got the bedside table we spent
everything change our color change it to
30 loofs press OK press OK and then
rotate our beds wherever we need them so
we can drag and drop them in see what
we're looking at and our beds are
underneath that corner window tucked in
to this space over here
we can duplicate once more on the other
bedroom wall rotate it around same thing
for the game's room grab a bed command T
open it up let's type in pool we've got
a pool table available to us and press
OK drag and drop a pool table into the
middle of the room
and maybe we have two pool tables for
some strange reason but just like that
objects are so easy to drag and drop
into space and all you have to do really
is search through your available library
and find whatever it is you're looking
for anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below if you missed any of this
arcad course series they are available
to the playlist the side of me but like
always I'll see you next Monday